Now, let's see how for this same cache,
we use this address to access the cache.
To make things easier to represent,
we will draw the lines in
the same set horizontally, so
these are the lines that belong to set
zero then we will have additional lines.
And there will be lines
that belong to set 15.
There are 16 sets if you remember.
So the way we access this cache
is we take the index bits and
they tell us which set we have.
Let's say we have set 0.
We then read the tag invalid bits for
all of the blocks in that set.
The tag bits that we read
are compared to the tag.
The valid bit needs to be also
1 in order to have a hit.
And we do this for each of these
blocks in the set simultaneously.
So the tag is distributed
to all of them to compare.
As you can see, there is four separate
activities in order to determine for
each of these whether it's a hit.
And then there is OR circuit that
checks if any of these is one.
If that OR returns a one,
that means that we have a hit.
In that case, what we do is we
find which one had the hit and
go back and read out the data for
that block.
Once the data is read out, let's say
this is our 64 bytes of data, we use
the offset to tell us where our actual
data to return to the processor is.
If this was a write, then this
offset tells us where to write.
And if this is a write,
we will also set the dirty bit here.
Note that we don't actually check
the dirty bit if it's zero and
set it if it's zero.
We just set it to one
regardless of what it was.
It's faster to just set it than
to check it and then set it.
So if we have a hit,
this is how we find the data.
What if we have a miss?
What if all of these have returned zero?
In that case, we will check the LRU
counters In these to find the one
that is 0,
check the dirty bit of that block.
If it is 1, we will first take this
data and write it to memory and
then put the new block here.
If it is 0,
then we simply bring in the new block.
We update the tag and everything here.
We set the LRU counters accordingly and
we then supply the data
to the processor.
So as you can see all of the stuff that
we have been talking about in the cache
really happens kind of simultaneously on
every axis all of this needs to happen.
If it's a hit up to here.
If it's a miss all the way
to writing back to memory,
fetching another block from memory and
updating the tag invalid bits.